let's hear from bill belichick he's at
number 17 in the peter king football
morning in america
power rankings belichick from yesterday
talking about
his top two quarterback options cam
newton and mack jones
cam has been here you know all the way
through um
he was here you know at the beginning
and you know has been
been a consistent participant you know
continues to give us the usual
um you know leadership and and um
you know energy that that he brings to
the field into the workouts and
and to practice so um
you know cam's cam is very professional
and i i'm sure that he'll
you know continue to work hard to do his
best out there like he's always done for
us it's never been anything but that
uh from the day he got here but really
we're starting everybody at the same
point like we always do
at this time of year so you know max
mac dove into the playbook and continues
to do that and
you know like everybody out there you
know we all have a lot of things we got
to work on and
that that includes everybody and and so
that's what he's doing that's what
everybody's doing
hey peter even though there's a little
nepotism on the coaching staff in new
england
when it comes to deciding who plays it's
meritocracy
and bill belichick is not going to
hesitate to put whoever
he thinks genuinely believes has
assessed and concluded
gives his team the best chance to win
that's who's going to be on the field
points beth thinks it's cam newton week
one at minus 275 that's an overwhelming
favorite
over mac jones at plus 250. i
i think it's whoever bill belichick
believes is going to help them win games
and if it's mac jones
he'll play mac jones if it's cam newton
he'll play cam newton and if he decides
during a game
that it's in the best interest of the
team to remove one guy and put in
another he will
he's proven that time and again
i think one of the uh you know it's
funny i was talking to
brian flores about this when i went down
to miami right after the draft
or in the middle of the draft and i
think one of the silliest things that
one of the silliest cliches in the
sports media business
and to some degree in the football team
business
is you got your starting quarterback
you can't waver from him you've got to
keep him in there even if he's
struggling
because if you take him out out of there
well you can't put him back
and who who invented that rule
who said that if you if your starting
quarterback
stinks this week that you can't put in
the back up and look it was easy
you had a rookie quarterback like
tuatanga velou struggles
ryan fitzpatrick comes in pulls a huge
rabbit out of the hat
in vegas last year and and that was
obviously that was the right call by
brian flores and it's one of the reasons
why i think
you have to know your team you have to
know your quarterback
if you've got a quarterback who might
have a bit of a fragile psyche
maybe you let him battle through things
like that but in my opinion
bill belichick exactly as you say mike
is really not going to care that much
about the psyche of his players
it is all going to be what gives us the
best chance to win
today and i i agree
points bet i'm sure is right that cam
newton is the overwhelming favorite
to take the first snap but if cam newton
struggles in camp
and mac jones stars in camp that's
that's going to change two quick
observations
one more important than the other first
we heard from tuatanga viloa this week
about the struggles he had
learning the playbook learning the
checks fully mastering the offense last
year
that helped explain why in crunch time
of multiple games
he was out and ryan fitzpatrick was in
and you better understand why that door
revolves a little bit more and as to the
idea of who invented that
i would be remiss if i did not mention
that
when you said that it reminded me of
estelle costanza trying merlot for the
first time and she said merlot i've
never heard of it did they just
invent it so i i was compelled to share
that
with you maybe that'll make its way into
an upcoming seinfeld
trivia uh block on pft
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports